[Music]  shadows  falling baby we stand alone  [Music]  oh  [Music]  [Applause]  me  hey barb yes star you know what i just  love what  movie trailers me too i like how they're  little movies about another movie before  a different movie  sometimes i find myself watching a  trailer for a movie  while i'm watching a totally different  movie too barb  what if we had a movie what then we'd  have to have a trailer oh yes listen i  wouldn't want to give  anything away though about the movie me  neither especially our faces  gosh i can almost see our trailer now  [Music]  holidays  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  oh i'd love it if it came out february  12th gosh i love that date  [Music]  you